um
so
okay yes yes chairman
lovely good evening everybody and
welcome to um watchful
council's remote review committee
meeting and welcome to anybody watching
this via live stream
start by agenda item number one which is
apologies for absence
um we do have apologies very late
apologies unfortunately from
councillors mr and mrs shaw um that is a
last minute um apologies for abstinence
due to family emergency
agenda item number two substitute
members
we welcome councillor wilson to the
green group
and councillor merrick for mrs shaw
chairman um council mrs mason councillor
mrs melissa you raise your hand
yes under apologies um for absence
uh obviously not seen in time but never
mind um
counselor eaves unfortunately has got
delayed
in south london and is unlikely to be
able to make it to the meeting in time
and you also have should have apologies
from councillor hookway who sent them in
because there is
substituting for him
okay thank you councillor mrs mason
yeah thank you mr chairman may i also
say that um
there's been an issue with um providing
me with documentation
um unfortunately the council sent it to
me and it's locked up my computer
we've only managed to get the my
computer back at 10 past seven
i haven't managed to read all the
reports okay so i'm going to give my
after item six um and i would like it
noted that i haven't had access to the
um
except report so i wouldn't be able to
save that anyway
thank you
okay thank you for letting us know
council mrs mason
um sorry just going back to agenda item
number two members
um substitute members just to reiterate
we've got councillor wilson for the
green group
and councillor merrick for councillor
mrs shaw
moving on to agenda item number three
non-members attending
councillor williams councillor fd
and councillor steptoe and i also
believe council of woodson as well
welcome all moving on to agenda item
number four which are minutes of the
meeting held on the first of september
2020 which have been circulated to
members
are members happy for me to sign those
when the opportunity arises
are you chairman yes great
councillor mrs mason have you raised
your hand
or yes mr chairman i have i'm afraid um
i haven't got access to the minutes at
the moment but like
from let me have a look
but there there is a problem with the
minutes
um firstly the um draft report was meant
to be circulated
to members for agreement i note that
came out today
and i wonder if there's a time frame for
that to be
actually responded to to yourself
because i'd anticipated it before this
meeting
um is there a time frame for that
um i will refer to something i think we
agreed sonia that it was by
this friday wasn't it am i correct
german it is this friday in order to
um give adequate time to feed into
publication of the uh agenda for council
there on monday
thank you and i would put it on
wrestling
to delay sorry the delay in that was
actually my
my fault and i have to accept
responsibility for that so i apologize
for the lateness
no that's quite all right mr chairman i
i'm sure we're all very busy at the
moment
um the other difficulty i have with the
is with the minutes is under the work
plan
that is um an inaccurate meet
a minute as it stands i'm just trying to
see if i can get hold of it too
um the work plan if you remember was
missed off the agenda
so therefore we could not um
and you allowed it to be added on
because of the error which that should
be noted in the minutes it shouldn't be
actually um ignored
but the other issue with that if you
bear with me
um yes it says here
in response to a member question a
related
question relating to the progress of the
managing companies i actually brought
that up and asked you to
put if we could discuss that which you
agreed to
and con noted that we hadn't had any
uh resources you had asked the officers
to provide you with resources because we
hadn't got the resource
since that meeting i have emailed the
officer and not had a response so at the
moment with the
i am the chairman of the working groups
the minute is totally wrong
um we are unable to make another meeting
because
either the the officers not provided
the documentation and if you recall you
asked um
if the council had adequate resources
and you that was going to be checked out
so i can only assume the council hasn't
got adequate resources
or if it has it's not providing them i
mean this is now 9 months 10 months
since the last meeting
but the question here is the minute the
minute is actually wrong okay thank you
council mrs mason
um i don't think any members would have
an objection
to it being nurtured in the minutes and
the work plan
wasn't initially included but um was it
was later added
i don't i don't think any members would
have an issue with that because i think
you're quite writing this amazing that
was
a more accurate description of of what
took place on the evening
if any members do have an issue with
that would you use the raise hand icon
now and if nobody raises their hand then
i suggest that we
do include that in the minutes the
revised minutes
it doesn't appear to be any objection so
sonja would could we arrange for that to
be done
and the other i had to imagine mr
chairman so is the fact about resources
you were going to discuss that and with
the officers
and i as i say i also emailed the
officer's concern
no response
i actually had to go back to the audio
recording to check that my recollection
was accurate
so i have checked it
okay thank you mrs mason um i think we
again we can note that in the minutes
and it something i will have to follow
up i did follow up with
the officers as well um
there is there is no simple solution
unfortunately i do believe that there
are
um resource issues um
and that's that's all i can say at the
moment um
sorry i said marcus hot and i can see
you raised your hand
if there are saucy um issues mr chairman
perhaps you could let us know
and we can take that up at the group
leaders meeting because it's not good
enough
that an important working group can't
have the resources to me thank you
okay at the moment i haven't had that
confirmed but i will com
i'll ask for confirmation if that is the
case and if it is certainly the case
we'll
we'll circulate that to members and
marcus did you want to speak
yeah sorry if i mostly interject on this
i mean we've had a brief discussion
around this today um i mean i think
there's been a bit of a vacuum
uh in terms of of who takes this forward
but i mean i i said
i'm quite happy to take this back up uh
and i've been contacting the working
group
um shortly so the next couple of days to
arrange a meeting soon
um most of the points i think they've
raised in the in the questions
from the last working group now we've
now collected the information together
uh so i'm happy to take that forward
again thank you
i think the problem there comes is it
was legal opinion we was
we were um speaking and um if you're
happy to provide that
then that's fine we sorry i guess we we
do have that
i think it just fallen between the
cracks a little in terms of there wasn't
enough to actually coordinate responses
so most of the responses actually come
back in
so we do have a legal response and i
said you know look it's just a question
of tidying up the loose ends and i'm
than happy to have that meeting
well thank you thank you marcus perhaps
you could contact me and we can sort
that out
it's of course thank you thank you
marcus
thank you councillor mrs mason um
we can just amend those minutes and then
if with those amendments
our members happy for me to sign the
minutes with the
amendments that we've just discussed
i'm assuming that as nobody has raised a
hand no one has an objection
okay thank you very much um moving on to
agenda item number five which is to
receive declarations of interest
including any whipping decorations
please raise your hand if
you do need to declare an interest
there are no hands raised thank you
members
so moving on to item number six which is
the
regulation of investigatory powers act
2000
otherwise known as ripper members would
have had
a report circulated to them this is an
annual report that comes before the
committee um
i'm going to um pass over to louisa moss
who attends the meeting for this agenda
item louisa the assistant director for
people and communities
and can i ask where he's in the usual
way we do
if you could just give members a brief
summary of the contents of the report
and then answer any questions that they
may have at the end
yeah thank you chair um just to
reiterate that this
is an annual update on the council's
covert surveillance
activity otherwise known as ripper
activity
and also it asks for note that there's
been some
changes to the ripper policy um
specifically around staffing changes and
changes to the name of authorising
applicants and officers
so um as i say as detailed in the report
it details for a further ongoing year
that there's been no ripper activity
which is probably um not so surprising
bearing in mind obviously the
seriousness threshold um
as detailed in our ripper policy and in
ripper itself
um we don't carry out any fraud activity
now um
investigations at the council and
haven't done for some while now
and that's with dwp and of course all
the responsible officers around
investigations generally have their own
processes around ripple authorization
especially trading standards
and the police so i just want to draw
your attention
to paragraph 4.3 4.4
um that refers explicitly to some overt
um surveillance activity around um
cameras
um because we've had some notifications
and letters
from the um camera surveillance
commissioner um quite recently
and as a result of a survey that he
carried out to all local authorities
across the country
and he's produced a report with a number
of findings
and that report unfortunately came just
at the time of publication of this
report so i've
committed to come back to review um with
some details around
how we propose to strengthen our
corporate approach and policy
around over surveillance with particular
reference to cameras
so um that's all i need to report and
summarize
any questions
thank you louisa um councillor wilkinson
good evening good evening thank you
sharon um luisa just
um very quick question i think you've
actually in fairness you've partially
answered this
um so perhaps i should have waited for
you to finish so i do apologize um
rip is something i was heavily involved
in my previous life
um we used to have authorities of all
sorts uh is this
usual for the council and forgive me
because i've only been on the council
for a year and a half this is usual
for us to have no authorities whatsoever
in the 12-month period and is that
because
we genuinely don't need to or is it
because you've you know have you had
applications that have been turned down
et cetera because i
when i know working with colleagues of
yours from the environment of health for
example
that they have processes in place they
have to do to get around the ripper
issues
and i just wonder if there are
circumstances or have been circumstances
where
you've been approached or whoever the
authority has been the officer has been
approached for an authority but it's
been turned down
and just to answer that it's um very
normal for us to not have
um any covert authorizations
um in part because of the um
you know the the actual sort of
seriousness threshold
we don't meet and we used to have them
um back in 2011 2009
and um having looked at them only
recently i note that they were
exclusively all around benefit fraud
um and where we had to do some quite
directed cover
um you know authorizations but it's very
common for us to have no i
activity under ripper um obviously overt
surveillance as you know there's two
distinct strands
is a very different type of surveillance
but ripper is quite normal it doesn't
come under ripper does it yeah no that's
right
okay okay lovely thank you
thank you councillor wilkinson um
louisa just referring back to um 4.4
on page 6.2 um it says that obviously
the commissioner's report and
recommendations were received 15
september
are now being considered by all local
authorities
having only just received the report any
changes needed to the council as your
policy will be a place and you've gone
on to describe that
can you just tell me when considering
whether or not these recommendations
i'm assuming this is what would happen
you will begin giving consideration to
these recommendations being included
in our policy is that something we do
just on our own as a local authority or
is this something that rochford will
be reviewing in association with other
authorities
now every local authority chair will be
looking at their own
um compliance against the um camera
surveillance assessment codes
um so we just need to look more closely
at our
um our approaches and probably
um at this stage i'm considering
adopting a
separate corporate um policy just to
align all our approaches so they all
sort of
line up so we'll be looking at it as a
local society in our own right
every other local society depending on
how much overt surveillance they have in
place
will sometimes already have policies so
the survey was carried out across the
piece
but we would be looking at it
individually
and just one last question from myself
louisa um
2.3 which obviously refers to ripper
training
um was undertaken in 2018 with refresher
training scheduled for this year
is there any update with regards to the
training that's proposed
and i suppose i do obviously i do
appreciate the importance of
training um but on this issue with river
bearing in mind how
seldom is used and has been for the for
the amount of years
is there a big cost
involved in training or um
online training has been provisionally
booked for the beginning of january
and it's all authorized officers and
obviously relevant portfolio holder and
members of this review committee that
are interested
to tell you the truth the commissioner
would expect us to have refresher
training around ripper and just online
investigations generally
and the cost for up to 20 um attendees
is approximately um two thousand pounds
okay
okay thank you very much
um i'm just looking it doesn't appear
that any other counselors
have any questions on me i will be
honest i'm not completely surprised
this is an annual london and for members
that have sat on the review committee
for
a number of years um they're very
familiar with this topic
um in that case members
we will uh need to there is obviously a
recommendation
and that that recommendation is to note
the amendments of the council's ripper
policy set out in section 4 to the
report
um so i'm going to move that motion
but i need to ask for a second second
second
mcpherson or wilkinson thank you both
for putting that forward
um we need to take a vote um voting will
be done by a row call of names which i'm
sure you're familiar with
um when sonia calls out your name please
indicate if you wish to have a recorded
vote
and then whether you are voting for or
against the recommendation
or if you wish to abstain thank you
um counselor mrs belton
no recorded vote for the recommendation
thank you
cancer burden no recorded vote
for the recommendation
counselor mrs gooding no recorded vote
full of motion thank you chair
counselor mrs mcpherson no recorded
vote and for the recommendation thank
you
handsome mrs mason
no recorded vote and for the
recommendation
thank you merrick
counselor no recorded vote
and for the recommendation counselor mrs
paglin
no recorded vote for the recommendation
thank you
councillor sparing no end for
councillor wilkinson
oh hello good evening councillor canel
uh also known for although miss off the
order
sorry i didn't see you yeah sorry uh
chairman
that's all right son you know just at
this moment of the meeting if i can can
i just
ask before you leave are you still there
counseling mrs mason
yes i i am yes um
councilman i do appreciate you you did
need to leave the meeting after this
i just wondered whether or not um
because obviously on the agenda
for this evening's meeting um we do have
a
an item that was called in by
yourself and two other members are
unfortunately unable to make the meeting
this evening
did you want to um go ahead with that
this evening in which case we might just
need a bit of detail on that before you
go or would you
like to um mr chairman is that in trying
to the
um the council sent it to me and trying
to
when i unlocked it using the password
that provided
it actually corrupted my computer and
locked up my computer
i haven't been able to read the exam
report
it's taken it took a considerable time
it wasn't until 10 past seven
that i couldn't even switching my
computer off it wouldn't release it my
my husband had his spend considerable
time sorting
out what had happened i believe it's
something to do with catches and
i don't know i'm not technical but
unfortunately i can't i can't comment
because i've got no access to any
documentation
um okay so i think it would as as the
the three members that called it in
won't be able to really discuss it i
won't be in a position to discuss it
this evening
would
you can carry it forward if you wish if
the timing allows
um otherwise there's no reason why other
members could not make a decision
okay was there any specific point that
you would like to
that you called it in this time because
i've got no access to any of my
documentation you'll appreciate i've had
15 minutes
to prepare for this meeting because of
problems that have been created
okay thank you council mrs mason i can
see that um
marcus hotlin has indicated to speak on
this so i don't know if you would just
want to listen before you
maybe leave for this evening and camp uh
marcus
so it's it would be wrong of me to
comment on something
when i haven't been able to see the
documentation that it's not been
provided to me
so it's me to
comment in that situation i mean we we
gave the reasons for calling in so it
should be quite clear
and i'm sure members uh are capable of
making a decision
thank you yep that's understood and
thank you for that marcus do you still
want to speak or do you want to wish i
think if that's the case
members still just discuss that item
this evening
as planned no that's that's that's fine
thank you
okay thank you very much thank you
councillor mrs mason
okay members moving on to agenda item
number seven
which is the waste and recycling
collection policy
and for this item this evening we
welcome marcus hotman associate
assistant director of place and
environment
and councillor williams the portfolio
holder for environment
um once again members you would have had
the
reports circulated to you um marcus
you'd want to run through this with
members just highlight any points that
you think need to be highlighted and
answer any questions and again
um counselor williams if if any
questions are directed to you
if you could answer those as best you
can
thank you and good evening uh it's a
relatively
short and straightforward report um
in essence um sort of it sort of
captures um
what is the existing waste collection
policy for this council into a formal
document
up till now we've not had any real
public document as such
uh it's been very much that we refer
back to um the
current contract but it's not something
that's available to the public
and so it's felt the term with the
member working group it'd be useful to
have something that's actually served as
a baseline
um from which we say this is our current
um policy and practices
and therefore when we change or if you
do make any changes whatsoever for the
new contract we can actually have
something to refer back to
i thought that till this time we didn't
have anything of that sort
so it's really just to formalize our
existing policy
uh and in many ways um the report just
brings your attention the document
that's attached to there
um which is which is the proposed draft
um waste collection policy
uh with key aspects such as bim
provision
contamination misspins etcetera um i
just want to
be quite clear to members that um i've
only asked them to note
uh the aspect of this because it's what
we already do
it's just trying to formalize this so
it's useful for member working group
going forward
that if we do make any changes to the
future contracts in two years time
that we have this is a reference point
to say well this is what we already do
and if we're making changes we are
comparing against that and i thought it
was useful for the public to have
something to refer to as well
hence the documents being produced i'm
happy to take any questions thank you
thank you marcus no one's indicated to
ask any questions in a minute but i'm
going to be honest
and say i've got a few um
firstly whenever a working group
undertakes a
project like this um you know my thanks
go to
all those members that have helped do
that um it's a it's a very thorough job
you can see that just from reading the
report and also
looking at the policy um the questions i
have
really are although i've got a few they
are fairly
minor and i do think it's important to
bear your comments in mind that this is
actually
something you're asking us to know
because we already do it
and i think that's quite important to to
bear in mind
um i think the first thing that struck
me about
the report it is very exciting i don't
expect it to be changed much
there are quite a few references
to charges being made
for various different aspects
in this policy yet the charges
seem if you were to read this policy to
be completely at the discretion
of the council and i do
worry that does concern me slightly that
if this was a guide for members of the
public
how that would be interpreted
it could possibly i i believe open the
council up to maybe some
criticism of unfairly
charging certain residents more than
others
i noticed there was a comment for
example about charging schools
at your discretion but that doesn't stop
you charging one school and not charging
the other
and i just wondered whether or not
there's certain things for charges for
the provision of bins
um charges for fines
is there any way that some of those
charges could be
put into the report i mean if we do
charge if we do make charges already and
if we do fine
would that not be worth putting into the
report just to make it very clear
um i i guess yes i mean obviously some
of it's already been covered such as the
bing collection policy
is something that i i think has gone
through full council
um a couple of years ago and so it's
also in the fees and charges so that
there's
i mean i think the wording around the
charging for bins is fairly
concise i think we're pretty referring
to i said more about the schools and
um medical waste is where the two areas
that spring to mind
and there's something we can say look at
um within the document
providing a bit more concise wording
around
well i mean in addition to that to my
comments for example
2.14 the district council will replace
free of charge any bin that damaged was
carrying out collection operations
excluding any damage because of
prohibited waste being placed in the bin
in which case a charge will be made well
who how much will that charge be and who
decides it
should yes
i mean that that's within the contract
yeah there are a few
comments like that through the policy
and and i quite agree with them and i
can see why they're there
but i think more so pays for clarity for
members of the public and b
to protect the council's position it
might be an idea to have those set out
and made clear that there could be no
ambiguity
over what those charges are and who's
deciding them
yes so that probably could be something
set out within the fees and charges for
example
yeah possibly yeah and councillor
sparing i can see you've indicated to me
thank you chairman uh having been on
that working committee
i think the the the point we were trying
to make
is that if you put everything down so
rigidly
you have no flexibility if a certain
situation
is a slight variation of something else
you are committed
to make charge and you you reduce
any opportunity that you have to use
common sense
you are obliged to do to follow the
policy
if you don't follow the policy then you
go down the road you've just said
you'd be accused of not applying the
same rules so
we felt it was better to use
say a little bit of flexibility and
and allow common sense to prevail i
think that was more the
the argument rather than being so
dictatorial
yeah and i think i can understand that
and i can understand why the working
group would
would come up with that conclusion but i
i don't know i think there maybe has to
be a balance i mean
again for example a collection and
disposal charge
is made for the service of removing
special and bulky collections
you know is that is our residence
charged the same is that based on weight
is it based on the
vehicle sorry i think
sorry if i can interrupt i think i said
i think um you want to save a set of a
fee within there because it's a policy
that stretches over a few years
but but if you refer to the fee i said
perhaps we should refer to the fees and
charges
at some point in the docking because the
fees and charges does set that price
so annual council each year if you can
think of the fees and charges that come
up for the um
with medium-term financial sort of
strategy um
they're agreed at that time so if you
look within there you'll see bulky
charges and
various charges the bins are in there um
there may be a couple more things be
more explicit but i think that's
possibly all that needs to be done is to
is to to refer to the fees and charge it
more explicitly
yeah i agree even if and i think
council asparagus makes a very good
point even if perhaps the charges
are if there's some sort of caveat
including the policy to say that
those charges and fees may be subject to
change
depending on circumstances but i think
it would give members of the public
um a clearer guide of the fees and
charges that they would expect to incur
um my other comments there's a couple i
think you've kind of covered
um the generally when you read this
policy and
again i don't disagree with it the onus
is very much
on the householders to get it right
and is for example
an unintentional breach of doing
something wrong which
i'm i think possible we've all done at
some point totally unintentional not
realizing
that can result in the you know
somebody's collection not being
collected on the time and waiting
another two weeks for it to be done
do the council think that they are um
doing enough to inform residents
of what their obligations are
that's a good question um i mean like
you say obviously the policy reflects
the contractual situation that we're
within
um but i mean that that's something that
um the portfolio and i have
discussed before about where we um
educate
enough and that's something we're going
to have to look at again i think so we
certainly
we do recognize that we need to do a a
better campaign
for example around contamination and the
like uh and and provide more information
in terms of what they call
bin hangers as to why your bin hasn't
been emptied that sort of thing
and that is something we're looking to
put into sort of practice in the next
sort of two or three months
so you're right to raise that it does
seem slightly
um stacked against the residents at
times it's not intended that way
but that's the if you like the
contractual obligation we're tied into
as well at times okay thank you
um councillor wilkinson
all right i was actually working hard to
put my hand down um because
marcus just answered my question i was
gonna i was gonna
completely support what you said
actually count uh chairman the because
i've had a couple of residents within
the last couple of months who've
contacted me and actually i think i mean
marcus may be able to confirm is i think
the issue is actually because
it's it's more the is it serious i think
who who've got the contract for this
isn't it is it serious
we have a contract and and it was um
i had exactly this where a couple of
residents didn't have their bins
collected for whatever reason they
didn't understand why there was no note
on there
at all uh and it took me the best part
of a week to find somebody at sewers
that would take the issue on
and work and they started to wait two
weeks and so so
i if for what it's worth um i would
completely support your
last comments uh chairman that i do
think that you know whilst i do accept
what marcus is saying the onus does need
to be on that on the household
because we can't be responsible for
everybody but i do think that we could
advise a bit better and that's how they
take it
further than that sorry if i may
i'd say that the existing contract has
that onus
um it's something we may well review so
you know
somebody needs to advise the household a
bit better that's
thank you um one other quick question
marcus on 2.8
the it say it states where the council
undertakes collections
by passing over a private road or drive
the property owner
will be required to indemnify the
council from any liability for damage to
the road
can i just ask how is that managed at
the moment
um i mean it is a and i think if you
read through some of the other parts of
the document
you'll you'll see that it's actually
quite a tricky thing to to do
um you know so so the answer is normally
is that that we would do so
if asked to collect um over a private
road but we'll make it quite clear that
we take no responsibility
for for the damage to that road surface
and you know so so it's um
normally um we don't have any issues but
where you know we occasionally
it's a situation where we will require a
letter to say that they are happy for us
to to enter across their
essentially their private land otherwise
what we do is we tend to say that we
were only click bins
from the public highway which is the
legal duty and so
there's some room for negotiation there
it's not straightforward
i mean you know it's almost a
case-by-case
um situation with private roads
i think just the reason i raised that
obviously my personal background
is in insurance and in particular
commercial liability insurance
and i know it would be very very
difficult
for the council to waive their liability
if they did
even if you had a letter from a
resident um agreeing to that
it would be very hard for the council to
to weigh their
liability sorry it's not such as
unprecedented again this could where
some clarity so it's not so much
indemnify against
uh let's say um general um public
liability
it's more literally the surface so if
they're saying um
we would like you to drive a 26 ton
lorry across
this driveway and we say we're not going
to
um because for reasons we don't think
it's going to hold up for that
and then we want some letter of comfort
to say yes that's fine
um we're happy that it will do so and
that's the level you're looking for
okay um councillor williams
yeah thank you chairman um i'd just like
to thank um
a.d marcus and mark sutton and working
group
members it's been the most excellent
report thank you all
uh councillor um wilkinson if you have
any issues with
um failed collections please let me know
i can always take this metro up for you
and i'm sure we can resolve it quick
more quickly than
very that thank you
thank you and my last very last minor
comment
um would be that at the moment
um and to be honest generally with waste
collection
certainly from my experience from
residents i don't really get too many
complaints or
or comments probably the one i get
or i hear the most is how
bins are replaced by
staff once they've actually been emptied
and again i i don't think that would
have hurt to have been put into the
policy that we've got that's
that the staff will do their best
endeavors
to replace it away from the pavement
there's lots in there about
what will happen to residents if they
leave their bins on the pavement
but very often and i've been in this
situation before when your bins are
collected early in the morning and you
don't come home till the evening
and your bins are scattered across the
pavement
um that can be a real issue and i just
wondered whether or not maybe there
could have been a comment in there
about that or just highlighting the fact
that we appreciate that they have a very
difficult job to do
and um it's not always going to be
perfect i think everyone
accepts that but i do wonder whether or
not it could just be there that they
would endeavor
to do that or something along that lines
um i can give it i can certainly get
some thought i mean it's um
like you say it is quite inflammatory at
times um it's probably the
what we call the replacement of bins is
certainly the
the key complaint that i i deal with at
times as well um but
but it's um it's a tricky one because
because sometimes what can seem like a
reasonable replacement to one person
um can seem unreasonable to the next uh
you know and i've had that um
situation to deal with uh many times now
where you know
even i will look and think well that
that seems okay but the resident is
still adamant that it must be within
uh almost a sort of an imaginary square
on the ground that they that they
understand
is dedicated to their bins so it's a
hard one to word
but i do take your point okay
thank you um no other members have
indicated any questions or asked to
speak
um so on that basis there is a
recommendation
um to note for this this agenda item
that recommendation is that
the council resolves to note the
contents of the report and attach policy
and i think
as marcus has already pointed out this
is because this policy refers to what we
currently already do
um if our members have it do i need to
take a vote for that i think i do don't
know
or cannot know i can't just note that
yeah don't need to vote
chairman okay if members if members are
happy to know then that's great if
you're not happy to know can you please
raise your hand
there are none right so i am assuming
that the whole
committee accepts that that's a note
thank you very much thank you marcus
moving on to agenda item number eight
which is the key decisions document
which
hopefully everybody has received a copy
of
um there are two items
on the key decision document
the first i'll refer to the the code
that's in the on the
left hand side seven slash 20
and that's the disposal of former
redundant crown hill
public conveniences subject to marketing
and granted permission for a future
leasehold agreement
um that's going i think we're november
2020.
i hope hopefully more members have seen
that
i have a feeling we might be seeing that
again
um any questions on that numbers or
no okay um moving on to the second item
on the key decisions document which is
eight
forward slash 20 and the subject is the
leisure contract beyond the 2020
21 financial year um
the decision to be by executive and the
date
when or period within which decision is
to be made is december 2020
there's obviously some details below of
what that is
have any members got any questions on
that key decision item
oh okay that's fine council of wilkinson
uh sorry
um yeah i was just gonna ask chairman if
i may on that
press that bank sorry for me on that
subject
matt's not with us actually but um does
anybody know are we going to wait until
because we're sort of in a bit of a
limbo period really aren't we with this
uh current situation because
you know i mean i speak i spoke to matt
a couple of times in the last few weeks
about it
and particularly was through clements
hall uh and how they're performing
um and i think they're still very very
much under review and so
at what point are are we going to make a
decision about
um reviewing this contract and looking
beyond march 21 does anybody know that
because
i don't think we're really in a position
to do that at the moment
i i don't know for sure um
i i briefly spoke to matt again a while
ago
several weeks ago now um but my
understanding is it probably would be a
bit too early to
to visit that at the moment and i think
although it says about the decision
being made in december 2020 i think
it is more likely to be around that time
council experience i can see you've
raised your hand did you want to comment
on that
uh thank you chairman i'm i'm not a
member of the
executive but i think it's fair to say
the whole situation regarding
any arrangements with leisure
facilities are under constant review
a substantial amount of money has been
invested
[Music]
for the benefit of both residents and
also the fact that it has secured
somewhere in the region of 150 jobs for
uh residents of this district however
uh as i say the situation is under
review
and i would suggest between now and
christmas time
further decision will be have to be made
because there is no doubt that
um
further requests is my guess will be
asked of the district council
for investment to maintain the leisure
services
and again that will be i say near the
time
has has the present system worked are we
getting good support and all the rest of
the things that go with it so let's say
as far as i'm aware and i believe uh
council williams may come in with some
comments as well
the thing the whole situation is is uh
under constant review
and no firm commitment says the
future commitments or where we go have
yet been made
thank you councillors bearing councillor
williams
yeah thank you chairman yeah i can
confirm
that dave has said um the situation is
very fluid at the moment i think we're
expecting the first reports to come in
mid to late october so
hopefully in the very near future we
should know how it's going
so thank you thank you council members i
think that's slightly
earlier than i was led to believe a few
weeks ago that is a that's a good thing
that's a positive thing so
um hopefully counselor will consider
that answer your question on that item
well yes as far as that you can um
chairman yeah i i have great questions
i think a big one sorry i said it is a
difficult one
to answer yeah the the reason i the
reason i i wanted to speak on it is
because um
and the reason i've had to speak to matt
a couple of times is because both times
um the company that runs the leisure
contract has been
referred to me or residents are referred
to me it's because of loss of jobs
um because they're making an awful lot
of people redundant at the moment
um and it's caused me some concern
um that as an authority we have invested
a lot of money which i respect that
there was a decision taken by the
executive
um and and yet we're still seeing jobs
going so i was
and i think i spoke to i think i spoke
to councillor whitney about this as well
but i think
i was starting some assurance really
that you know that they are being
monitored um and you know that we are
getting value for money out of it so
that that's really why i wanted to
mention it but i i said what council
willing to said obviously it's a fluid
issue and something which is ongoing so
far as review is concerned so thank you
very much john
thank you councillor wilkinson
okay um moving on to agenda item number
nine which is the work plan
and hopefully all members have got a
copy of that in front of them
you can see that that has changed it has
been amended and updated since the last
meeting
there are just a couple
of things to note um for instance the
review
of the constitution and
also the review of the council's
overview and scrutiny function um they
are both entered in for november
at the moment they will remain there
however
um due to um
well there's possibly going to be some
developments on that
and it may be a bit premature um to be
bringing that before review
in november for it to be effective on
either of those so
if anything does change members will be
notified as soon as possible
and um but we will really have to take a
pragmatic approach
um with regards to these two items as to
if we call them in too early
it it just might it might not be an
effective move um
there might not be an awful lot to
review um
so we do need to keep our eye on those
but at the moment they are staying in
the november
work plan and but they may be subject to
change but if they are we will let you
know as soon as possible
with regards to the uh
january item which is one that
we are asking members of the public to
nominate any topics or issues
um actually sonic i've got my notes on
that can you just um
brief members very quickly on what the
plan is for that
yes um basically what i'm hoping to do
is to uh is to uh finalize
a um a sort of a survey
form that we will put up on the council
website and
um and advertise on our social media
channels
so that um we're encouraging residents
to come forward with uh with any ideas
for uh for the committee to review uh
with the view to looking at that in
january
thank you sonya um so obviously if any
members want to
to mention that to any of their
residents if any of the residents have
come forward to them
and ask them you know which residents do
can you look in this
can you have a look at this um it may be
worthwhile going back to those residents
and ask them to nominate those subjects
and
and hopefully get it before review and
we did it a couple of years ago and then
it was successful so
hopefully we can repeat that this year
if any members got any questions
regarding the work plan
okay okay so moving on to
gender item number 10 exclusion of the
press and public
so i will now move a recommendation
under section 100
a 4 of the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following item of business
on the ground that it involves the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph three of part
one
of schedule 12 a of the act
can i have a second please
thank you
moving on then to agenda item number 11.
this is um the review of grounds
maintenance and street
cleansing contract sorry sonya
am i able to move on to agenda item
number 11.
just one moment chairman thank you
okay just